hi I'm Howard Rodman I'm president of
the Writers Guild of America West and
also chair of the 2017 scriptor
selection committee curious what you
would recommend to beginning writers on
trying to publish their screenplays or
protect their work what are some of the
first few things you recommend sure the
first thing I recommend the beginning
writers is that the only way to
absolutely guarantee that you will not
have a career as a writer is to quit and
so what I recommend to beginning writers
is real simple real basic that you write
every day in terms of getting your work
out there in the world even if you're
shy or a shoe gazer you have to be
aggressive on behalf of your work and
get it into the hands of anyone who
might conceivably read it as painful and
humiliating as that process is in terms
of protecting your work you should
absolutely copyright it but to see in a
circle get the form from the US
Copyright Office you can do it online
it's really simple and also register
with the writers guild the to give very
complimentary protections for work from
new people
you were a writer as well you've written
screenplays okay you talk about the
first film that inspired you to want to
write no I am a writer see the calluses
and there are so many films that
inspired me to want to write that pick
one would be I think crazy but I do
remember there's a scene at the end of
an old film war boxing movie called body
and soul I believe written by Abraham
Lincoln Polanski directed by Robert
Rawson and in it there's a boxer very
proud sort of first-generation scrappy
immigrant boxer played by John Garfield
and the mob boss is offering him a lot
of money not to win the fight because
all the money has been bet the other way
and John Garfield starts talking about
his pride and his morals and the ethics
of throwing a fight and the mob boss
turns to him and says there's addition
there's subtraction
the rest is conversation and I just
thought whoa one of those and you know I
think for many of us we start reading
books and watching movies because
somebody has built a world and that we
can just hide in that world for a while
and then you realize at some point oh
wait I could build my own sort of
purpose-built world that would really
fit me and so the transition from movie
going to reading to writing I think for
many of us is just a slow descent into
the pit so the first screenplay that you
wrote did you have the similar sort of
dream of that was going to be the first
one and the one to put you on the map
you know many new writers think that the
first screenplay will open doors in the
first draft I never had any thoughts
like that I you know spent well over a
decade writing unpublishable novels
before I'd transition to writing
unproduced screenplays so I was under no
illusion I just had started having ideas
that were movies that weren't quite
books
and the first of those screenplays I
wrote still has not been produced but
I've gotten tons and tons of work off of
it it's sort of like of course we can't
do this because this is too weird but
you know maybe you can do that and so I
don't think I ever really expected
frankly that anything I wrote would ever
get filmed and when things I write do
get filmed it just strikes me as sort of
like the bonus rounds in a pinball game
you know it's sort of unexpected and
really lovely and lastly just wrapping
up here because I know you have to go
and wondering what do you see is the
most common mistakes or some things that
new writers should be wary of regarding
formatting structure things like that I
would tell beginning writers not to
worry so much about formatting and
structure in terms of formatting there
are many really good screenwriting
software programs and some some of them
you can get for free and so let them
worry about the formatting in terms of
the structure I think the worst thing
you can do is to say oh my god my first
act didn't end on page 29 I'm a bad
writer if you find real living
characters if you're telling a story
that only you could tell or writing
about a place of the world that you know
better than anybody else just let the
story tell itself or let the characters
tell the story and the rest will fall
into place so just kind of get what well
for lack of a better term the vomit
draft he's my my crass analogy but get
that out and then worry about all the
other things later no I wouldn't even
say that I would just say you know I
used to work I was the editor-in-chief
of my college newspaper and there's a
big sign of the newspaper office
underneath this huge that had a
like a blood-red second hand and the
sign said this is a daily not a weekly
and whenever we were there past midnight
the manager
editor would put up another sign that
would say don't get it right get it
written and I would say the same thing
to people starting out writing and to
people who've been writing all their
lives I love it thank you
thank you very much